hey everybody welcome back to let's play
joined by some more Huseyin today oh
it's a game tomorrow night for little
while it's called dead cells see little
it's been flying under radar somewhat
yeah for me it's got potential to be
Game of the Year you know it's a it's an
excellent game and it's the only an
early access as well so yeah in HD and
it's always amazing I'm one of those
people that's always quite reticent to
play early access games I don't I'm not
a big fan of playing unfinished games
and then trying you know being part of
the process of finishing them I know a
lot of people aren't into that and I
respect that but I like to a game to be
fully formed yeah there are certain
games where I'll wait for them to come
out like I am the new divinity original
sin that's an only access but I'm
waiting for that this game though it's
in early access but I kind of played it
just because I had nothing else going on
and it was it looked really really
appealing it's got a DNA that all of us
can appreciate yes like part Dark Souls
part Metroidvania yea-ah
rogue legacy yeah and it's really
polished for a early access game like
the main things that you'll see that are
missing are features like online
connectivity but the fundamentals of the
game and the way it looks and plays are
all intact and as you can see from a
super fluid it's it's looking real good
it's probably worth having one as well
is yeah so this is dead cells its par
Metroidvania part rogue legacy part Dark
Souls all that's done and you are the
prisoner who's been you know you're
dropped into your prison you can't die
it's got that rogue legacy thing of like
you progress you die you start again but
you kind of you keep that progress so as
you defeat bosses you unlock new
abilities you unlock new weapons that
can be unlocked throughout the game it's
a it's like pretty deep you start off
it's just you know a sword and a basic
wooden shield and then eventually you
unlock all these new abilities those
blue things you see me pick up our cells
you trade those cells in at the end of
each section or level to unlock more
equipment I'm like 16 hours in so what
you're seeing now is quite developed
usually to start with a rusty sword and
a wooden shield
these are challenge rooms I've yet I
think I finished one challenge room yeah
in there like eight hours I played it's
it's a very tricky game it does test all
of your skills like platforming skills
and your reaction times and your ability
to like Mega Man style your ability to
figure out our boss's weakness run
enemy's weakness and exploit it while
also protecting yourself with movement
like their for example it's a lot of a
lot of dodging like I don't really take
the shields I prefer having a ranged
weapon yeah so you kind of have to dodge
it's got that blood ball mechanic of if
you react by hitting an enemy when
you're wounded you get a little bit of
your health back the game right now has
I think has three paths you get the
ramparts which is I think is the easiest
path the sewers which is moderate path
and then the graveyard what you saw
there is me picking up you get skills
which is basically utility items so I
got flashbangs and stuntpeople yeah it
might be worth explaining the roguelike
element of it and how your progression
carries through from one playthrough to
the next well as you see I'm picking up
cells I've got three right now so I've
already explored this level once I've
unlocked those unlocked something with
those cells I keep that the rest the
rest of the game forever basically if i
unlock a certain sword
there's the ossuary that's a hard hard
mode if i unlock a certain sword i'll be
able to use that for the rest of the
game as long as i find that sword again
yeah and there's certain enemies you can
beat to unlock abilities you saw me
trance teleport between two
sarcophaguses that you have to defeat a
certain enemy to unlock that but then
once you unlock that ability you have
tours the game it's a these runes on the
on the right here and you can see
there's only two of them in the game
right now with this space for like seven
yeah so I don't know whatever else is
gonna put in yeah so although you're
kind of you're quite fragile and you
will be replaying the same l impart of
the game over and over again there you
do still get that sense of progression
in your character and the mastery comes
along with that when you kind of
understand the route as you go along it
is generating levels procedurally right
on the way and so nothing
the levels themselves won't be exactly
the same as you go through but your
understanding of the enemies and and the
kind of the abilities that you have to
navigate them will grow of time and
that's kind of where the progression and
the skill based element of it comes like
for example the way Dave's playing now
is only because you've been through this
area more awful time yeah like hours in
this game yeah first start you are
cautious no.1 that's one of the reasons
why this game speaks to you and I so
much because with such souls fan yeah so
the first climbing through this area
it's like literally pixel by pixel
movement just to make sure that you're
not unnecessarily losing your health and
you know mana recovery items are very
limited so you spend a lot of time in
the first few playthroughs being super
cautious and playing reserve but once
you've done enough time in here you can
be a little more ambitious and a little
more show you with the way you get
around because you know how the enemies
behave and you know where things are you
understand the logic of the game and the
language of the game yeah and another
reason is um I've got an item that my
potions the the ones you sit like
basically what it's my Estus flask I've
upgraded it enough with all the cells I
found so I've got like four heals in me
instead of just the normal one one you
start off with one and then as you
upgrade cells you should talk about the
movement because that's something that I
found to be quite quite exciting for me
like usually you don't get these kind of
games they're usually you're quite
grounded like even stuff like
Castlevania so for that but whereas this
has got like double jumps - is straight
from the outset and like err dashes and
that kind of stuff yeah you've got the
double jump you can then use ground
pounds you saw there yeah that's one of
my favorite our ground pound is a great
great addition for this game yeah it's
really satisfying see the way you just
got down there Wow son he's dead it's a
dead guy and the way you've got down
there that roll super fluid Pacey
especially if you're playing it the way
that I play it um this this is this a
new feature it's just gone through the
elemental update yeah that's why I was
not doing a video on it now it's just
been updated again
so this is a blueprint if I acquire a
blueprint that means the item is then
unlockable if I use enough cells I kind
of want to go through the harder path
though to show some of that I can always
go through an easier part later because
now I've got a broadsword blueprint when
I go to hand in my cells I'll be able to
unlock unlock that said weapon by
putting cells into here it's a way to
explain your seat in a second let's just
go through here so this is that actually
the hardest path I'm sorry but the heart
of the path the more stuff you can
unlock there's certain things you can
unlock and certain paths so this is a
guy you have to give all your cells to
you actually have to give all your cells
in before it lets you through I can
actually unlock that yet for more and
I'll be able to unlock it
there's a couple here that I've closed
too but when you unlock it you actually
just get one yeah if I were to finish
unlocking it then he just drop one for
you so it's kind of like but otherwise
everything else you need to find in the
wall yeah but it's nice because
otherwise you have to block cool just
unlock this weapon that I've just been
keeping hold of yeah and you recovered
your your health potions there as well
and if I was to die before getting to
that chap I would haven't I would have
lost that blueprint I would have lost
all my but I lost would have lost a
bunch of my money again one of the
upgrades I have is that I keep 85 85
percent my cache god these guys are Wow
yeah guy wait
he loved exid I've only got level one
items coming down here was a risk but I
love the art style in this game yassuh
is great and there's a crap ton of
effects going on which I really really
appreciate like I love the the Lightning
effect when you recover your health
I love his shining one eye yeah which is
really cool when you when you turn up
you're just a dead ball that yeah
reoccupied your body the ground pound
animations real cool
another roguelike element is it it is
actually CG generated of what you get on
each level see standard on a level you
probably get like three upgrades but I
got two so my health is still level one
so this area might be a little tricky
but see what you can do also this game
has great music game does a great music
oh that's my actually log went out my
way to find the soundtrack on Bound
Bandcamp and you can perfectly down here
you can download it which is that's one
thing that's not super common in the 2-d
game like atmospheric music yeah I'm not
making too much use of Mike this is this
PC only at the moment but I think
they've got plans of yeah I think
they've got pledges of hitting it ps4
will be mentioned anyway yeah and also
our god I would call for a portable
version right if this is on switch oh my
god
system seller like this this game is
like a member the exact price but it
wasn't expensive and I've already put to
my 8 hours into it yeah I bought a site
on see like I saw it and I love the
style of it so much that I just bought a
straight away and then it kind of
everyone else was talking about on tour
at the same time and nothing it for a
couple of weekends and it was the talk
of the games industry yeah and there's
no games like I said it kind of flew
under the radar but yes it kind of got
some traction it every was like
this yeah and it continues to be a like
people are talking about as much but
it's still an X in an excellent game and
they're putting in a lot of work to it's
changing on a weekly basis yeah like I
said we just went through the elemental
update yeah
there's already been a couple of things
that are new to me the finally got the
achievement guy working you know and
fundamentally it's just so satisfying to
play that I mean it's gonna carry on
improving but even if it stayed as it is
now I think I'd continue playing it for
a good dozen more hours yeah I've not
seen everything that this area access
version has to offer like you I've got
past the first boss and maybe a level
after him but I've just died after that
yeah so that those things that they saw
and briefly before but these are the
elite enemy rooms and I'm like 100% sure
if I suddenly enemy I'll die sometimes
you're not going to right now and
there's there's interesting part of the
game like for example the time doors
we're not seeing a time door yet Oh God
but I think how it works is all other
levels are procedurally generated those
doors they're kind of anchored in the
world so they'll always be yeah you
should always come across at least one
of these doors and so you'll always know
where it is but the trick with them is
they're on a timer so like if you may
have like three minutes to get to them
before they lock yeah so like come on
run yo you you got to have them in mind
and be like I'm gonna go for that door
straightaway and kind of like hightail
it there yeah if I don't have the items
to support that speed then yeah you're
in chance a ditch won't happen and if
you don't get there in time it it gives
you a full rustle by telling you how
long ago it closed I've got to a door
before that said I was zero seconds away
I'm like but that means you should open
and my thumb's are go for doughnuts like
you were three seconds late it's been
like ah then you're there's other times
you're doing like a nice slow pace II
run yeah and it's like you are 13
minutes late you know are fair enough
there yeah alright so since I died there
I'm gonna kind of go a little faster so
like I said the promenade of the
condemned is considered like the easiest
route mu K you can change routes as you
go through here
I like this one because it's got a
little more verticality yeah the other
one is the sewers which is pretty
claustrophobic yeah and the ones that
you saw earlier was the ossuary just I
mean God it's got the same downside that
a lot of like procedurally generated
levels do sometimes you'll find areas
that are kind of strangely crafted yeah
I'm a lot of like dead-end rooms that
have nothing in them but it doesn't
happen a lot in this game I found no and
I think you move at a pace that when it
does happen it's just like you're out
there within seconds you can usually
tell are there's nothing in here and
you've like double jumped and - out that
room before just really randomly or what
is going on down there okay oh this
elite is the worst it's just like
harasses you think the shield elite is
my least favorite this I once once you
heard them enough they just start
teleporting oh god damn it and he's got
these little boys with him there we go
no give me a for shield I don't want no
shield man and I'm a damage the best
defense for me in this game is a good
offense flying-type enemies there
that that's super annoying these these
are really interesting those that we're
dumb crash test training dummies with
dummy thing you have to destroy it
otherwise it keeps giving enemies around
you shields which is interesting
strategy element especially when some of
the enemies are bloody hard enough this
broadsword is pretty are you increasing
that like yeah that's my death orb
alright that's pretty cool just in all
the movies you can solve it as a massive
damage and I'm alright with that the
abilities that you have in this game
they kind of remind me of the abilities
that either card has in Symphony of the
Night oh yeah
yeah so he had the ability to you know
like dark metamorphosis for example but
the difference in that game is you had
to do like weird inputs like almost
fighting game style like inputs like a
core circle forward and punch and he'd
do it early I really like that mechanic
but it doesn't have that kind of input
element to it but it does have the
ability style so you can have these
strange useful often to interventive
abilities on the goal as well which is
really cool yeah there's a lot of ways
you can play this you can just kind of
go full tank and try and do the
blood-borne build where you're taking
load of damage and doing enough damage
to kind of keep you alive or you can
play super glass cannon which is the way
I usually play to varying degrees of
success
yeah it's error can you damage yourself
with bombs and stuff now you can roll
into your own games which I did a lot I
think there's a well at least i'm
throwing so many now if I was going to
damage myself playing bombs I would be
dead already
I've not found a curse chest yet yeah
the curse chests are really cool this
this is a lip balm on zwip it's it does
only does its max damage when you hit an
enemy with its tip so involvement and
like I'm not yeah when you're in like a
cramped room it's it's just rough here
powerful enough if you're super accurate
with it though then my favorite weapon
so far is the rapier yeah and does
critical hit every time you roll your
health so the curse chest we should
probably explain our chests that give
you an item but at the same time you
upset the gods by taking the item yeah
if you get hit and it usually is like
you're killing 10 enemies you just dad
you'd want hit kill yeah so give you a
number of enemies and an enemy quota
that you need to kill before the curse
is lifted but if you take a single hit
before that happens you're done which is
a screw let's give isness and I gotta be
brave big brave dog and get those sick
items ah rolled is that bomb Claud the
music in this area it's super super
chills relaxing but then like your
fighting is very nice that's an ability
that you unlock fairly early one of the
first ones really ability to create that
vine yeah and climber you kill like a
certain enemy it lets you tickle vines
it actually says tickle tickle vines and
then they sprout up and you can climb up
see we could change route now and go to
the old sewers so let's do it let's do
that so kind of yeah get show some
variants so you can start for the
promenade and go to the sewers or the
graveyard you don't have to stick on the
route
let's buy the attack up so I need to
find some more blueprints because it
started to kind of finish up a lot of
the stuff that have hmm grid the rape
you so as well as unlocking them you're
improving them so that next time you
pick one up it's yeah once you once you
do the base unlock you can then keep
putting cells in you do 5% extra damage
temps and outer damage the return on
those isn't exactly great your fifty
cells sometimes but big fan of that
aggressive elevator animation another
callback to a symphony other night
if you had to take that elevator down
you would seriously break your shins in
symphony of night when you use the
elevator at akkad actually like grunts
as you lunge that wall wow that's a lot
of bombs
oh god the spikes the shield guys are
pain in the bottle it's when you get
shield guys and the guys that have
spikes on the back of the same area it
was like where do I hit you actually
know you could just duck under those
over right there i canti doesn't panic
those like alright let's try it
enemy is not very smart trying to get
through that oh very smart trying to get
through that
oh here's the trek amigos alright guys
chest look at I'm gonna be brave be big
still a bug you outrageous a gods it's
guilt enemies but it's giving me a meat
grinder five so that might help me kill
the enemies without actually going into
no go be extra careful god no my god
first thing it gives it Oh what is that
it's fine
go back on the meat grinder there you go
I just I see this rune here but it's
going to take me to a challenge room
where I'll bible 100 certainly get
killed so these are bugs and white
biters one of my abilities is one of its
one of my abilities ability it's summon
biters oh those yoga me oh boy these
these little boys do they recover
healthy I don't think they do I just do
a bit damage
yeah they just hit hit my enemies for me
alright five more oh dear but those bats
like one hit kill you sometimes Oh guys
lift it boy yes I can go back to being a
bit and aggressive more aggressive but I
got like a super powerful ability that
like a level 5 ability doesn't really
show up this is so it's only reading
those cursed chests or you'll get them
it's that risk reward factor oh that's
new oh oh that was a decent dodge
or looks tight but yeah I didn't see
that second second Bombeck give me like
a BAM you have to be like super vigilant
if you're on those seniors
so much happened on the screen that had
to not know what was enemy damaging my
damage that's copying up there oh sweet
five hands chilling up you can get
automatic turrets as well in this game
wow really I didn't know that yeah
they're just shoot arrows but they will
also Agra enemies so one of the best
combinations is a the buzzsaw trap and a
turret huh yeah and they just drop them
on each other you just like a boss
killer if you're careful Oh
spikes I don't want no shields fam that
ain't my style
what's up kebab kebab nice bit of Health
there super rare as well ah mushroom
there's mushrooms they put their spikes
on the floor so when you're trying to
dodge other stuff the same time it yeah
super annoying area-denial god I love
that it's so sad for both so satisfying
and then when you pair that with being
like low health as well and just
recovering so much can you add proper
you threw the thump um there's some
items that will like let you do extra
damage with your stump I think I don't
want a bear trap not a phaser bird rubs
see all diving attacks leave flammable
oil on the ground so could technically
be good but at the minute I've got like
a 15% damage reduction so I think I'd
rather keep that no I don't that was on
the last run let's take it especially
since I've got the flame brands but the
only reason I've got so much money is
because I like up I put souls into the
upgrade which lets you keep so much
money after your death right so you kind
of have to do sometimes you'll do like
money runs yeah yeah grind runs those
are the best ones for paying very little
attention to like is that well Chuck on
a podcast I'll watch a TV so sure while
I'm doing like resource grinding runs
then it means when you come to do like
another run in five times five runs time
yeah got like go back to my gold buying
all the things am I going
you can't be school that's a handy map
in the corner to keep you abreast of
where you're supposed to be going or
where you've been I don't know is it I
don't know if it's leading to a dead end
or what's going on them these big brown
blob maggot looking things
I swear yet these guys don't usually
spawn though yeah these are
I've never seen these guys before
they're a pain in the ass
I don't know if this is like a slightly
new enemy type but it comes to like this
zombie putting so much like area of
effect damage down though they just melt
Wow for real get bombs on I'd like
another weapon yeah this one seems like
it it's a bit slow it is slow I mean it
is doing massive damage brilliant down
low oh I always prefer speed though yeah
I'm the same
I'm just think about if it gets the boss
it's gonna need some speed and finesse
to it you have to dodge that guy's so
much this is a mushroom app
not sure how I got through that without
taking them and I'll take it it is
better to leg it sometime yeah this
thing is well looking through there
that's new I've never seen that before
hmm what to do though oh wow
you ain't having my rooms from my
breasts X knees flipped in the bed I
think I'm gonna go back all right it's
his room I'm gonna hot guys there's a
shield over my head as well which I
don't know where that has come from so I
wonder if he's part of getting the next
rune or something or if he it's like a
mechanic's way hun trade him Mia
um what's our health a house at three
let's go for damage keep that glass
cannon style going no I'm not in that
I'll die like this should take us the
next area there we go black bridge so
this is where the first boss lives you
do three area well you do the starting
area two levels and a boss and then I've
only ever done two levels after that so
I don't know what the next boss evening
is was it rape you see it's only on ten
plus 10% and it's already like another
hundred cells I'm missing three health
smiles on top of pricey I think this
this broadswords only level two so you
can just be unlucky in some runs like
you're gay loads of abilities and loads
of upgrades but you'll be stuck with
your base weapons Sam look at
I early I just want at it when I first
told his boss
it does that horrible ability where
every time you get near any edits you
depending on what items you've got this
can be a super tricky boss yeah my first
time was real rough there's a feature in
the game when you're using range weapons
like a crossbow where your your bolts
your arrows will actually get stuck in
the enemy so if you're going like a full
ranged run you can just run completely
out of ammo because all your ammo is
stuck in the bag in the BigBoss yeah so
changing up now he's now doing jumps and
[ __ ] that's what got me yeah the jumps
kind of come out of nowhere
it's usually his range floor attack
against me there is Oh
that's how much damage save the heel it
comes the jump
get on my bloody abilities my sordid
doing enough I'm sure your Billie's have
called down to Coralie spammin oh wow
dammit
okay that was worth that was worth that
wasn't worth you know I've got no more
heels want my help
Oh unfortunate that he showed off like a
good variant of the game the game is
bloody hard like but I highly recommend
you try off yourself like you see here
we just start again you get you get a
bunch of cash back you've got some noise
you get some you got some knowledge you
get get some base weapons going on and
you just go again all over again but
that's gonna that's going to do this for
this let's play guys thank you so much
for watching we highly recommend you try
this game check out basically if you
want something a bit different a bit
something you can just drop in out of as
well if you liked the video make sure
you hit the like button subscribe for
more videos like this one
and we'll see you next time ye